monsieur c'est aussi bonjour merci
d'être en direct sur rt france alors
c'est donc le président tunisien qui a
demandé de lui même à elias a far far de
démissionner il coupe un peu l'herbe
sous le pied du parti annahda qui avait
engagé une motion de censure contre lui
est-ce que ce rebondissement politique
illustre d'une manière ou d'une autre
les tensions qui existent entre le chef
de l'état et le parti ahd narda selon
vous alors selon moi ça illustre surtout
une tension entre le pouvoir législatif
et le pouvoir exécutif en tunisie parce
que certes il y avait une question du
parti islamiste mais il y avait
également une volonté de l'exécutif a
gouverné sans majorité c'est à dire que
ce qui s'est passé dans les derniers
mois c'est que lles parfaire a commencé
à 11 ans même de son gouvernement un
conflit interne majeure qui s'est
ensuite transformée en volonté de
remaniement et d'exclusion ddd ministres
issus de naves alors au ski qu'est ce
qu'on a vu hier c'était une course entre
la motion de censure du président de
dieu du président du parlement et la
demande de démission du président de la
république l'enjeu étant que celui qui
obtient la sortie de faire faire en
premier garde le pouvoir sur la
prochaine nomination
justement cette démission risque de
plonger la tunisie dans un nouveau cycle
d'instabilité politique alors
l'instabilité politique oui mais ce qui
est ce qui est dangereux aussi avec
cette démission c'est que on a vu
l'échec d'une autre période
d'instabilité qui était la nomination de
liesse parfaire ou rappelons le passeur
et à choisir un candidat qui avait fait
0 38% élection présidentielle un
candidat qu'il n'était pas soutenu par
là par les blocs parlementaires citées
pas du tout le candidat le plus
consensuel c'est à dire que la majorité
s'est formé autour de la pression de la
dissolution du parlement et ce n'était
pas une majorité de conviction si l'on
veut et cette période
l'idée qu'on va subir maintenant et
conséquence directe de ce choix et on
espère en tout cas que si le choix
revient après ça aide encore une fois
qu'il va choisir quelqu'un qui obtiendra
une majorité réelle au parlement non pas
sous la pression de la dissolution et
qui pourra gouverner avec les partis
dont avec lesquels il salit la dernière
question monsieur aussi quelles
conséquences cette démission peut-elle
avoir sur notamment la gestion de la
crise sanitaire on sait que la tunisie
est épargné par le coronavirus mais on
pense aussi au conflit libyen qui est à
la frontière et qui inquiète à la
tunisie bienheureux il ya plusieurs
questions qui vont être mises sous
silences et qui vont disparaître du
débat public pendant pendant cette
période à cause de deux siciles
constitutionnel de cette émission parce
que notamment ce qu'on fait depuis 2014
depuis 2011 c'est une judiciarisation du
débat où l'on parle uniquement de la
constitution et la politique s'est
résumée à ddd guerre de constitution
constitutionnaliste alors que comme vous
l'avez dit la crise endémique n'est pas
finie et surtout lorsqu'on voit depuis
quelques semaines c'est d'aider des
mobilisations sociales assez forte
on attend encore les retombées du
confinement qui ne cesse d'augmenter et
qui pourrait avoir une conséquence
majeure à la rentrée et si un
gouvernement n'est pas ne n'est pas prêt
à répondre à ces problèmes sociaux on va
se retrouver avec une crise qui peut
dépasser l'aspect constitutionnel et
théorique
merci beaucoup monsieur aussi d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes essayiste tunisiens vous étiez
donc en direct de tunis